donc du jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de la relative aux outils de
lutte contre la désertification médicale
des collectivités présentées par
Monsieur Danny watteblé et plusieurs de
ses collègues et dans la discussion
générale la parole est à l'auteur Dany
watteblée pour 10 minutes
un collègue que nous
interrompons la discussion générale à
13h pour respecter leur drogueur qui a
été fixé donc nous n'irons pas tout à
fait au bout monsieur wattmet à la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le Président a
commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
la désertification médicale ne cesse de
progresser en France derrière ces
espèces
courantes il y a une réalité pour 49
millions de Français de français
nous avons tous entendu les mêmes récits
et les mêmes questions
comment faire renouveler son ordonnance
quand il n'y a plus de généraliste
comment accéder à un spécialiste quand
ce dernier n'a pas de remplaçant comment
se faire soigner s'il y a pas le médecin
près de chez nous
lutter contre la désertifier son médical
est un enjeu de santé publique pour une
population qui augmente qui vieillit et
souffre de plus en plus souvent de
maladies chroniques
dans certains territoires il faut
parfois attendre 20 jours pour obtenir
un rendez-vous chez un généraliste
pour les constellations chez un
spécialiste les délais augmentent ne
serait-ce que pour attendre 5 mois
quelquefois pour obtenir un rendez-vous
chez nous ORL
c'est un vrai problème en terme de soins
de dépistage au risque d'aggravation de
l'état de santé des patients
c'est aussi un problème pour tous les
prochaines de santé confrontés à une
charge de travail très importante et pas
forcément entièrement consacre consacré
à la médecine
et cela explique également le désintérêt
des étudiants et des étudiants pour
l'exercice de la médecine générale
en libéral
pendant 50 ans le numéro slausus a
contribué atterrir l'offre de soins
sa réforme en 2019 est une bonne
nouvelle mais nous savons tous il faut
il va falloir attendre quelques années
avant de voir ses premiers effets
d'autres réponses ont été apportées
toutefois la politique monnaie associée
à ceci insuffisamment les collectivités
les îles le coup se retrouvent démunis
face à des départs de médecins et ils
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens pour
rendre leur territoire attractif afin
d'en faire venir de nouveau
pourtant les maires font preuve
d'initiatives et proposent des réponses
innovantes
nous devons leur faire confiance
j'en veux pour preuve que l’activité se
sont systématiquement et pleinement
saisis de chacun des outils en matière
de santé mis à leur disposition
par exemple les collectivités ont été
innovantes en étant à l'origine de 23%
des centres de santé
ils ont également été pragmatiques et
volontariste en proposant des mises à
disposition de locaux ou des aides
financières au médecin qui s'y installer
face au désarroi de nombreux mères il
m’a apparuti leur donner de nouveaux
moyens pour agir en matière de santé
nous savons tous que les médecins croule
sous les tâches administratives
nous pourrons comprendre leur acétude
d'arriver sur un nouveau territoire avec
une nouvelle patientèle sans personnel
administratif
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé de rendre
possible la mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux auprès de
cabinet médicaux et de venant de santé
dans les dans un désert médical
pourquoi dès qu'on fonctionnaires
territoriaux
en réalité c'est une évidence imaginons
une commune mettant à disposition un
personnel de mairie afin d'officier
temporairement en tant que secrétaire
d'un cabinet médical
c'est agent étant parfaite mesure
d'accueillir les patients et d'apporter
un appui administratif au médecin il
connaît les prophètes de sortie locaux
ainsi que les habitants et peut assurer
une bonne coordination entre eux et le
médecin nouvellement arrivé c'est simple
pragmatique et efficace
avant de continuer je vous remercie
chaleureusement l'ensemble de la
commission il aura perdu un Chassin pour
leur accident travail
fort de son expérience
en tant que médecin généraliste en
milieu rural lecteur Chassain
appartement compris l'esprit que j'ai
voulu donner à cette proposition de loi
et l'intérêt pour certaines communes de
recourir à ce dispositif
ainsi à titre proposé une nouvelle
rédaction particulièrement claire afin
de délimiter le dispositif avec
précision
le texte de la commission jolie soumis
aux voix d'autres hôte assemblée ouvrent
la posture territorial située dans les
airs médicaux de mettre un agent à
disposition d'un médecin uniquement s'il
exerce la mission de ces publics
de permanence de soins pour une durée de
trois mois renouvelable deux fois et
seulement à son arrivée sur le
territoire
le droit commun prévoit sauf dérogation
que le salaire de l'agent doit être
remboursé par la structure d'accueil
aussi ce dispositif peut-il se concevoir
comme une avance de trésorerie par les
médecins nouvellement arrivés
il s'agit de donner aux illiochos la
possibilité d'accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions un médecin alors
qu'il y en a plus
une fois lancé le médecin reculera son
équipe ou bénéficiera des différentes
aides proposées par la Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie ou les agences
régionales de santé
et l'agent recouvrera ses fonctions
initiales
les cabinets libéraux doivent bienvenus
rester libéraux mes chers collègues
l'urgence de la situation nous oblige à
faire feu de tout bois dans la lutte
contre la désinfirmericale je vous
souhaite tous concernés et je compte sur
vous je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
à part est à présent à Monsieur Daniel
Chassin rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales
également pour 10 minutes
sur le président madame la ministre même
la présidente de la commission mes chers
collègues depuis 2015
l'accessibilité des consultations chez
le médecin généraliste ça reculé dans 86
départements
à un autre territoire les plus fragiles
se transforme en désert médicaux tant et
si bien que près de 9 millions de nos
concitoyens disposent aujourd'hui 9
Médicis insuffisantes pour répondre à
leurs besoins en santé trop de fois déjà
la commission des affaires sociales a eu
un diagnostiqué l'origine du mal un
manque de médecin lié à l'application
aveugle de numerus clausus trop
restrictif on est bien sûr la cause
principale avec insuffisamment de stage
en premier cycle pour découvrir la
médecine libérale trop peu d'interne
dans les hôpitaux périphériques et
cabinets médicaux conséquences d'une
action publique décidée à l'échelle
nationale en associant insuffisamment
les collectivités
aujourd'hui nombre d'administrés
expriment leur désarroi leur sentiment
d'abandon et parfois même leur colère à
leurs élus locaux souvent démunies face
à des départs de médecins fausses de
levier d'attractivité suffisant pour en
faire venir de nouveau la proposition de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui a été
déposé par votre collègue d'animaux
l'article unique du texte vise à élargir
la liste des entités éligibles à la mise
à disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux à en y ajoutant les
cabinets médicaux et les maisons de
santé en zone soudain le texte a été
adopté par la commission les affaires
sociales modifiée par un amendement que
j'ai porté celui-ci tout en restant
fidèle à l'esprit du dispositif en a
précisé le champ encadré la durée
conditionné l’éligibilité à la
participation au service public de
permanence de soins ambulatoire
répondant ainsi à certaines observations
formulées lors des au
la mise à disposition consiste pour un
agent public réputé occupé son emploi en
l'exercice de ses fonctions hors de
l'administration où la vocation servir à
ce jour la mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux est ouverte
auprès d'une liste limitative d'entités
qui sont soit de droit public soit
exerçant une mission de service public
soit à titre expérimental et sur un
champ restreint sont des organismes sans
but lucratif le texte se situe donc
entre rupture et continuité vis-à-vis du
droit de la fonction publique rupture en
signe de l'engagement de législateur
dans la lutte contre la désertification
médicale puisque le dispositif ouvre la
mise à disposition à des entités de
droit privé à but lucratifs mais dans la
continuité dès lors que le texte
adoptait en Commission maintient bien le
lien
consubstantiel unissant mise à
disposition et services publics en
conditionnant cette dernière à la
participation à la permanence des soins
ambulatoires
l'objectif de ce texte madame la
ministre mes chers collègues et donc de
proposer un accompagnement humain
articulé avec les différentes
dispositifs existants pour aider
ponctuellement l'installation de
médecins en zone soudain aujourd'hui la
plupart des dispositifs de lutte contre
certification médicale se concentre sur
l'appui financier logique aux nouveaux
arrivants ces dispositifs pour une
composante essentielle pour revitaliser
notre activité médicale mais il ne
doivent pas éclipser l'accompagnement
humain du médecin libéral dans les
semaines suivant son arrivée sur un
nouveau territoire qui demeure encore
aujourd'hui un angle mort des politiques
conduites
pourtant si l'on veut éviter que médecin
installé ne plie pas bagage précocement
il convient de s'abstenir de le laisser
livrer à lui-même lors des premiers mois
d'exercice au moment où il a besoin
d'appui dans ces démarches
d'installation chronophage dans les
tâches administratives qui occupent une
part importante du temps des médecins
sont encore accrus à l'arrivée sur un
nouveau territoire avec une passe
nouvelle patientèle à gérer pouvoir
partager voir déléguer une partie de
cette charge administrative un personnel
mis à disposition serait une manière de
répondre aux préoccupations légitimes
des médecins en la matière et pourrait
ainsi contribuer à lever une barrière à
l'installation
des contraintes organices en gaz
organisationnel également exercer la
médecine sur un nouveau territoire dont
on ne connaît ni les caractéristiques ni
l'écosys un professionnel en place peut
avoir tout d'une gageure à plus forte
raison pour les médecins venant de
l'étranger les représentants des
professions médicales auditionnées se
sont montrés très intéressés par la
possibilité de recevoir l'appui de
fonctionnaire territoriaux pour le
médecin pour la coordination avec les
autres professionnels de santé du
territoire lors des premiers mois
d'installation la rémunération du
fonctionnaire mis à disposition
inversée par l'administration d'origine
puis rembourser dans les conditions
fixées par la mise à disposition
les salaires du personnel mis à
disposition feront obligatoirement je le
répète l'objet d'un remboursement
intégral par l'identité
bénéficiaire et de dispositifs et donc
neutre à terme pour les finances des
collectivités dès lors ce texte ne
viendrait pas s'il devait être voté nous
l'espérons alimenter une quelconque
forme de concurrence financière de
l'éther entre collectivités comme le
craignait certains élus auditionnés les
personnels mis à disposition pourraient
des agents mairie d'intercommunalité ou
du département qui seraient chargé de
l'accueil de la patientèle de la gestion
administrative notamment du classement
des dossiers de rentrée des documents
dans le dossier par médical partagé
de coordination avec les autres
paramédicaux qui je le rappelle ont
besoin de prescription pour leur travail
auprès du patient
réception de demande ou de transmission
de documents de documents sont
journaliers pour les infirmières pour le
kiné pour les orthophonistes pour les
pellicules etc de la part du médecin et
des paramédicaux et inversement mais
aussi informé par exemple les personnes
qui attendent si le médecin a dû
s'absenter pour des soins non programmés
urgent
parfois même prendre des rendez-vous au
niveau des spécialistes ce personnel mis
à disposition sera seulement
très souvent mi-temps de manière
temporaire trois mois renouvelables de
fois
pour que le médecin arrivant trouve ses
marques et puissent recruter son propre
personnel en ce sens ce texte loin de
faire doublon avec les autres
dispositifs existants et notamment les
assistants médicaux en fait le
complémentaire le fonctionnaire mis à
disposition à vocation à passer le
témoin à un assistant médical ou un
secrétaire médical recruter sur un
contrat de droit privé bien sûr par le
médecin mais qui aura eu ponctuellement
un accompagnement personnalisé à son
arrivée cette proposition de loi ouvre
donc la possibilité dont pourront se
servir les collectivités qui le
souhaiteront à ceux qui disent que les
communes n'ont pas les moyens humains ou
financiers je souhaite rappeler que ce
discours positif proposait et bien sûr
facultatif et qu'il est remboursé
d'ailleurs les
collectivités se sont jusqu'à présent
pleinement saisi de l'ensemble des
potentialisés que leur offre à date de
la loi en matière de santé elles sont
elles ont été innovantes
en étant à l'origine de
23% des centres de santé à activité
médicale elles ont été également
pragmatique et volontariste en proposant
des mises à disposition de locaux vous
le savez maison de santé ou médicale ou
de cette financières aux médecins qui
s'y installerait chers collègues dans la
mise cette proposition de loi ne
permettra pas de résoudre le problème de
désertification médicale elle n'en a
d'ailleurs pas l'ambition mais je
demeure je demeure convaincu à la fois
en tant que rapporteur et en tant que
médecin exerçant en zone soudance que
cette mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux peu importer
une réponse intéressante à déployer
localement pour accompagner je le répète
ponctuellement les médecins dans leur
installation
facultatif
temporaire et neutre sur les finances
des collectivités le dispositif ne
comporte en outre pas de risque ni de
fait ni ne fait de perdants par
conséquent mes chers collègues j'espère
que ce texte sera trouvé une majorité au
sein de notre assemblée je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
et je donne la parole à Madame Agnès
Firma le Baudot ministre délégué chargé
de l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente sur Catherine de roche
monsieur le rapporteur cher Daniel
Chassin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement se réjouit de
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de cette
proposition de loi portée par Monsieur
le Sénateur Danny wattley dont je veux
salé ici l'initiative et le soutien du
groupe Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoire elle rejoint pleinement la
philosophie de l'action du gouvernement
celle de reconnaître le rôle majeur et
décisif des territoires pour faire
émerger des solutions
issues des initiatives locales et avec
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés car
l'enjeu majeur dans le contexte
démographique tendu que nous connaissons
sur les professionnels de santé c'est
bien de mobiliser tous les leviers
existants pour trouver du temps médical
et augmenter la tractivité de tous les
territoires je veux le rappeler le
gouvernement est pleinement engagé en
faveur de l'accès aux soins avec une
approche basée sur la territorialisation
de notre action afin de construire
partout avec l'ensemble des acteurs des
solutions les plus adaptées au contexte
locaux
car nous en sommes tous convaincus la
réponse ne peut être unique et identique
sur l'ensemble du territoire en matière
de formation d'abord avec le soutien à
la réalisation des stages en ambulatoire
pour les internes et les externes avec
la mise en oeuvre de la quatrième année
de médecine générale pour faire
découvrir la pratique en libéral et
donner envie à nos étudiants de
s'installer et exercer en ville pour
créer ce short d'attractivité dont nous
avons besoin nous agissons également en
faveur de l'exercice coordonné avec la
poursuite du déploiement des maisons et
centres de santé pluriprofessionnels et
des communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé j'ai lancé
d'ailleurs ce mois-ci un grand tour de
France des CPTs pour identifier ce qui
marche et ce qui marche un peu moins
bien dans les structures déjà existantes
et dans celles qui se crée notre volonté
c'est de proposer des leviers
d'amélioration pour permettre d'ici fin
2023 un maillage du territoire couvrant
l'ensemble de la population
nous souhaitons également accélérer le
déploiement des assistants médicaux avec
un objectif de 10 000 assistants
médicaux en 2025 pour cela nous aurons
besoin des élus et des collectivités
territoriales en effet aujourd'hui l'une
des difficultés que nous rencontrons
c'est que les cabinets médicaux ne sont
souvent pas adaptés pour accueillir ce
nouveau métier dont l'objectif est de
libérer du temps soignant il nous faut
donc anticiper ces questions dès le
montage de projets des nouveaux cabinets
mais aussi apporter des solutions
concrètes d'adaptation des locaux
existants nous travaillons dès
aujourd'hui avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes les élus locaux les
professionnels de santé au cabinet
médical de demain
ce sera l'un des volets du pacte
territorial en santé avec les élus qui a
annoncé le président de la République et
qui se déclinera dans le cadre du CNR en
santé durant les mois qui viennent un
autre défi que nous rencontrons c'est
celui de la simplification et de la
suppression des tâches administratives
qui empoisonnent la vie de nos médecins
c'est la feuille de route du ministère
qui est le mien au côté de François
Brown pour tout faire pour simplifier la
vie des médecins lui février dernier
nous avons présenté 15 mesures pour
réduire le temps administratif des
médecins l'objectif c'est de redonner du
temps médical et améliorer durablement
les conditions d'exercice des médecins à
titre d'exemple les certificats médicaux
doivent devenir l'exception on sait que
les médecins ils passent en moyenne
entre 1h30 et 2 heures par semaine
aujourd'hui supprimer la délivrance des
certificats médicaux non nécessaires
cette autant de temps retrouvé au
service des patients
il était urgent de clarifier les règles
pour les domaines concernés que sont les
crèches les écoles ou les fédérations
sportives ce sera bientôt chose faite
avec des campagnes d'informations
régulières pour mieux informer patient
institutions sur le caractère non
nécessaire de certains certificats nous
agissons également pour déployer des
outils numériques mieux adaptés au
quotidien des professionnels de santé en
particulier les médecins libéraux la
proposition de loin que nous examinons
aujourd'hui s'inscrit aussi dans le sens
d'un plus grand partage des leviers mise
à disposition des acteurs dont les
collectivités territoriales pour
faciliter la vie des médecins et
encourager ainsi leur installation dans
les territoires elle va dans le sens
d'un enrichissement de la boîte à outils
que nous souhaitons mettre à disposition
des acteurs locaux et donc pourrait
s'emparer certains maires pour agir
concrètement sur l'accès aux soins
elle s'ajoute aux mesures votées en LSS
pour 2023 en faveur de l'installation
des médecins je pense notamment au
guichet unique départemental et à la
simplification des aides à
l'installation l'objectif c'est bien
d'offrir plus de lisibilité de souplesse
pour un effet une efficacité renforcée
dans le cadre du CNR en santé qui se
poursuivra dans les prochains mois la
mise en oeuvre de ce guichet unique
départemental trouvera toute sa place ce
sera d'ailleurs l'un des objets portés
dans le cadre de la deuxième phase du
CNR en santé que nous allons lancer
d'ici la fin du mois et qui a vocation a
rassembler de façon régulière tous les
acteurs territoire par territoire pour
partager les besoins en matière de santé
et construire des solutions adaptées aux
réalités du terrain en utilisant
l'ensemble des outils que nous mettons à
disposition
le dispositif de cette proposition loi
porte cette même volonté celle de
simplifier la vie des médecins en
facilitant les conditions de leur
installation dans les déserts médicaux
via la possibilité pour les
collectivités territoriales de mettre à
disposition un agent administratif
durant une durée limitée un médecin
aujourd'hui pour être pleinement
efficace doit pouvoir être accompagné
d'un secretariat médical ou d'un
assistant médical cette aide est souvent
demandée par les médecins ont lieu et
place du net financière mais aujourd'hui
le droit ne le permettait pas en
commission des affaires sociales vous
avez souhaité en préciser le champ en
soulignant le rôle d'amorçage de la mise
à disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux d'où sa limitation dans le
temps vous avez également souhaité
conditionner le dispositif à la
participation du bénéficiaire à la
mission de service public de permanence
des soins ambulatoires le Gouvernement
est favorable à ses ajouts et vous
proposera par souci d'équité un
amendement visant à permettre aux
fonctionnaires des trois versants de la
fonction publique de particip er au
dispositifs proposés sans rien enlever
au fond de la proposition de loi dont
nous partageons la philosophie cela nous
paraît de nature en favoriser
l'opérationnalité tout faire c'est
déployer les outils nécessaires ce texte
vous en conviendrez avec moi monsieur le
rapporteur à une portée limitée mais il
est bienvenu parce qu'il participe de
notre volonté commune de déployer tous
les moyens pour répondre aux besoins en
santé de nos concitoyens
et comme cela a été dit cela ne retire
rien à personne si vraiment une faculté
proposée c'est une avance de frais et
limitée dans le temps il y a de jours
ici nous débattions et tous sur ses
bancs avaient défendu la possibilité que
les collectivités territoriales
s'investissent pour répondre aux besoins
de santé de nos concitoyens vous avez
ici la possibilité de le faire je vous
remercie
madame les ministres merci
nous poursuivons la discussion générale
et la première oratrice et Madame
Monique de Marco
copé-colistes solidarité territoire pour
5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues c'est la sixième fois en
quelques mois qui nous débattons de la
question de l'accès aux soins cela
démontre l'urgence de la situation et du
manque de réponse à la hauteur du
gouvernement
ce constat est connu et s'aggrave un peu
plus chacun des pour atteindre ses
critique dans un certain nombre de
territoires
rappelons quelques chiffres 8 millions
de Français vivent dans un désert
médical et 6 millions d'entre eux n'ont
pas de médecins traitant
60% des habitants du territoire ruraux
connaissent des difficultés d'accès à
médecin généraliste depuis les années
2000 de nombreuses politiques
d'incitation à l'installation des
médecins dans les zones soudains ont été
mises en œuvre
par exemple financement d'assistant
médicaux des contrats d'engagement de
service public passez avec des étudiants
des maisons de santé ou encore du
passage numérique clausus un humérus à
Perthus mais celui-ci va mettre quelques
années à produire ses effets
bien que ces mesures soient utiles et
restent clairement insuffisante les
écarts entre les territoires les mieux
et moins bien dotés se creusent si les
dispositifs de soutien financiers aux
étudiants en contrepartie d'engagement
de service permettent d'accroître
l'offre à court terme les résultats à
long terme sont beaucoup moins probants
les incitations financières ne suffisent
pas attirer et retenir les médecins dans
les zones soudains et l'impact de ces
mesures est assez faible au regard des
coûts
les dispositions de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 n'auront pas eu non pas non plus
offert de réponses satisfaisantes elle
crée une quatrième année d'étude pour
les médecins généralistes mais cette
mesure reste assez floue il nous paraît
donc évident que le dispositif de cette
proposition de loi ne répondent pas aux
problèmes
cet article unique prévoit d'ajouter les
cabinets médicaux et les maisons de
santé à la liste des entités pouvant
bénéficier de la mise à disposition d'un
agent public dans le cas où la
collectivité se trouve dans une zone
sous dense avec pour objectif d'alléger
les contraintes financières et
administratives pesant sur
l'installation des médecins dans ces
territoires
clairement nous nous opposons à cette
proposition qui flèche des moyens
publics de la fonction publique vers des
cabinets libéraux
les fonctionnaires territoriaux n'ont
pas être mis au service du moins ça ne
peut pas être une priorité par ailleurs
ce dispositif paraît peu repérationnel
si la mise à disposition se fera sur la
base du full antariat ils ajouteraient
une contrainte supplémentaire aux
petites communes qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de se passer d'un de leurs
agents ni de l'arrivée d'un médecin
l'examen en commission est également
souligné un certain nombre d'écueils un
agent municipal non soumis au secret
médical et donc ce n'est pas le métier
cela nous semble un peu risqué dans les
faits
face à l'urgence d'autres mesures de
planification de l'offre et une réelle
régulation de l'installation paraissent
plus efficace
c'est ce que le groupe écologiste a
défendu à plusieurs reprises notamment à
l'occasion du dernier PLFSS d'autres
mesures sont également a prioriser par
exemple la prise en compte par les
facultés de médecine du nombre de
candidats originaires de zone Soudans en
premier cycle dans leur l'élaboration de
leurs capacité d'accueil autre exemple
la prise en charge des frais de
transport pour lever les difficultés
d'accès aux soins ou encore
l'effectivité de l'accès aux urgences
dans la maternité à moins de 30 minutes
ces mesures doivent s'inscrire dans des
réformes structurelles qui engagent le
long terme
il faut véritablement rééquilibrer notre
démographie médicale et mettre fin à
cette iniquité territoriale qui ne cesse
de croître pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
votera contre ce texte
notre collègue Théophile n'est pas à
l'instant dans la séance donc il
interviendra plus tard et la parole est
donc à Madame le wérou
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains et elle dispose de 9
minutes
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur madame
la ministre chers collègue la France est
un désert médical les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes 87% du territoire français
est un désert médical Paris comme la
Nièvre sont des déserts médicaux tels
étaient vos mots madame la ministre à
l'occasion du 104e congrès de
l'Association des maires de France en
novembre dernier notre pays connaît en
effet de grandes difficultés de
démographie médicale toutefois ce n'est
pas une fatalité et le problème mérite
un plan Marshall pour apporter à tous
nos concitoyens une offre de soins
correspondant à leurs besoins
nous n'en pouvons plus de voir l'offre
de soi se dégrader pour s'adapter au
moyen disponibles alors qu'aucune
perspective d'amélioration ne se profile
le constat est connu je n'y reviendrai
donc que brièvement la France a perdu
plus de 5000 médecins généralistes entre
2010 et 2021 alors que la population
s'est accrue de 2,5 millions d'habitants
sur la même période la situation est
alarmante 11% des Français soient 6
millions de personnes non pas de
médecins traitants ce sont plus de 8
millions de Français qui souhaitent d'un
praticien proche de chez eux ne peuvent
consulter plus de deux fois par an ce
phénomène s'aggrave également du fait de
l'augmentation de la demande de soins
liée au vieillissement de la population
du développement des maladies chroniques
et du départ à la retraite d'un grand
nombre de médecins généralistes non
remplacé
les inégalités territoriales d'accès aux
soins ne cesse de se creuser vivre dans
une zone soudante multiplie par deux le
taux de renoncement aux soins la perte
de chance pour certains d'entre nous est
une réalité inacceptable dans notre pays
où le système de santé est basé sur la
solidarité nationale selon l'adresse se
renoncement et multiplié par 8 lorsque
le fait de vivre dans un désert médical
ce couple a une pauvreté en condition de
vie s'il touche en priorité les
territoires ruraux les déserts médicaux
existent aussi dans les territoires
urbains tels que l'Île-de-France et de
manière accrue dans nos départements et
territoires d'outre-mer qu'elles soient
liées à la fermeture des urgences ou à
l'absence de praticiens à proximité les
difficultés d'accès aux soins entraînent
une dégradation de la qualité des soins
susceptibles de mettre en péril la santé
et la vie de nos concitoyens cette
situation dramatique devient ins
responsable à vivre pour les patients et
insoutenable à porter pour les élus qui
se battent sans relâche pour trouver des
solutions des réponses concrètes et
ambitieuses sont plus que jamais
nécessaires pour préserver notre modèle
de soins pour ne pas laisser nos
concitoyens dans la détresse sans
solution pour se soigner et afin
d'assurer l'égalité d'accès à la santé
il appartient au législateur et au
gouvernement d'agir la proposition de
loi présentée par le sénateur Dany vate
Blade du groupe indépendant République
et territoire que nous examinons
aujourd'hui en temps apporter une
amélioration à la situation dégradée que
nous vivons dans nos communes cette
proposition de loi vise à autoriser la
mise à disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux auprès des cabinets
médicaux ou de maisons de santé ce texte
s'inscrit dans une logique intéressante
pour libérer du temps médical et
faciliter l'intégration d'un nouveau
médecin sur leur territoire la mise à
disposition fonctionnaire local devrait
ainsi répondre à la préoccupation de
médecins prêts à s'installer en zone
soudance mais qui serait inquiet des
conditions financières et
administratives à supporter toutefois
bien que le texte prévoit un dispositif
facultatif au collectivités volontaires
cette proposition de loi suicide
l’étonnement et les réserves de la part
des associations d'élus tout d'abord
concernant le caractère opérationnel du
dispositif nous y voyons plusieurs
réserves quel est l'articulation avec
les autres dispositifs existants
notamment celui des secrétaires médicaux
ou des assistants médicaux dont
l'assurance maladie facilite l'embauche
grâce à une aide financière conséquente
de 36000 euros par an sous réserve d'un
minimum de patients et d'exercer de
manière coordonnée la proposition ne
prévoit pas de financement de l'État ou
des ARS ce dispositif à la charge des
collectivités très justement modifiée
par le rap porteur Chassain qui quoi le
remboursement de cette charge par le
médecin pose une difficulté à un moment
où les marges de manœuvre en ressources
humaines et financière des collectivités
sont restreintes et alors qu'elles sont
elles-mêmes confrontées à des
difficultés de recrutement enfin les
personnels mis à disposition nécessite
une formation adaptée à la terminologie
médicale ou aux outils de gestion de
l'assurance maladie formation qui n'a
pas de lien direct avec la formation des
fonctionnaires territoriaux cette
formation minimale n'est conséquente ne
vaudrait que pour quelques mois compte
tenu de la durée du dispositif limité à
trois mois renouvelable dans la limite
de deux fois un recrutement direct et
dès l'installation sur un contrat privé
nous semble plus adapté l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui ouvre la possibilité
aux trois versants de la fonction
publique dans la fonction publique
hospitalière pourrait améliorer ce point
mais dans l'état actuel de l'hôpital
public se remet la pire que le mal
l'hôpital public souffre déjà d'une
hémorragie d'une fuite de ces agents
qu'il faut plutôt colmater il convient
également de rappeler que ces agents de
la territorial sont soumis aux devoirs
de réserves et à la discrétion d'usage
mais ne sont pas soumis au secret
médical contrairement aux assistants
médicaux ceci posa un vrai problème
susceptible de fragiliser la relation de
confiance entre le patient et le
personnel médical par ailleurs le
caractère optionnel du dispositif risque
d'accroître les inégalités territoriales
et ainsi amplifier la concurrence entre
les collectivités sans effets global sur
l'attractivité médicale lors de l'examen
en commission le rapporteur a très
justement réécrit l'article unique de
cette proposition de loi tout d'abord il
encadre la durée du recours au
dispositif il la limite à un maximum de
3 mois renouvelables deux fois les
fonctionnaires territoriaux n'ont pas
vocation à se substituer durablement au
personnel des libéraux et des maisons de
santé libérales le rapporteur
conditionne le dispositif à la
participation à la mission de service
public de permanence et soins
ambulatoire en cohérence avec le droit
en vigueur en matière de mise à
disposition pour pallier tout risque de
détournement ce dispositif à
principalement vocation à accompagner
les médecins à leur arrivée sur un
nouveau territoire toutefois nous
pensons que d'autres mesures sont prises
par la RS en lien avec les collectivités
au travers des contrats locaux de santé
de la mise à dis en place des
communautés professionnelles
territoriales de santé la CPTs de
l'appui apporter à l'installation pour
accompagner un nouveau médecin qui
s'installe sur une commune le guichet
unique une installation se prépare et
doit déjà s'inscrire dans un exercice
coordonné en lien avec les autres
professionnels les collectivités sont
sollicitées au-delà de leurs compétences
pour financer ce dispositif incitatifs
je rappelle que la santé est une
compétence à qui appartient à d'établir
une offre de soins équilibrée sur
l'ensemble du territoire l'origine du
problème tient au manque de médecin et
de professionnels de santé non pas par
manque de vocation car nombreux sont les
jeunes souhaitant s'investir dans ces
métiers mais par inadaptation des
recrutements de la formation et du fait
de la désorganisation actuelle de notre
système de soins la mise à disposition
d'un fonctionnaire et une procédure
administrative lourde qui prend du temps
car elle doit faire l'objet d'une
information préalable de l'assemblée
délibérante et de l'accord préalable de
l'intéressé ces préalable au vu des
trois mois de mise à disposition pose la
question de l'efficacité relative du
dispositif pour les communes concernées
pour lutter contre le désert médicaux
surmonter la crise de l'hôpital et pour
pallier le manque d'attractivité des
métiers du soin et de la santé il nous
faut un grand projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation afin
de répondre aux enjeux de santé de la
population un plan Marshall pour un
accès à tous et toutes
tout sur le territoire national rural
urbain ou ultramarins devient une
urgence nous comprenons que les
intentions des auteurs de la proposition
de loi sont louables mais ce dispositif
nous apparaît comme étant une fausse
bonne solution nous partageons les
réserves des associations des lus
notamment l'association des mers ruraux
de France et l'Association des
départements de France vous l'aurez
compris pour toutes les raisons à
évoquer le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicains ne votera pas pour cette
proposition de loi il votre a contre je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à Madame Cohen
pour le groupe CRCE et pour 5 minutes et
Madame guidez pour également s'exprimer
avoir la coupure
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lutter contre la
désertification médicale des
collectivités territoriales est une
urgence que personne ne peut contester
de nombreux chiffres en atteste il n'est
pas acceptable que 30% de la population
française vivent dans un désert médical
les difficultés pour prendre un
rendez-vous avec un généraliste en
secteur 1 n'est plus une situation
spécifique au territoire ruraux elle
concerne désormais également les
territoires périt urbains et urbains
face aux difficultés d'accès aux soins
la colère monte chez nos concitoyennes
et nos concitoyens mais je m'interroge
sur cette nouvelle initiative
parlementaire le Sénat a déjà discuté de
six propositions de loi en moins de 6
mois sur l'accès aux soins cette
proposition loi arrive en sciences
publiques alors que votre groupe est la
majorité sénatoriale ont voté en faveur
de l'ensemble des budgets de la sécurité
sociale qui ont pourtant entériné la
réduction des dépenses de santé on peut
donc s'interroger sur l'objectif réel de
cette initiative parlementaire qui
arrive quelques mois avant
renouvellement du Sénat depuis 2017 vous
n'avez pas contesté mes chers collègues
insuffisance des moyens mis en oeuvre
par le gouvernement et le remplacement
du numérique clausus par le numerus
apertus qui n'a augmenté que de 200
médecins formés par an pourtant les
besoins sont estimés à plus 20 % en
médecine plus 14 % en odontologie plus
6% en pharmacie et plus 4% en maiotique
sur le fond cette proposition de loi vis
à lutter contre les déserts médicaux en
améliorant l'attractivité des
territoires par la mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires territoriaux pour assurer
le secret le secrétariat des cabinets
médicaux en zone soudance alors mes
chers collègues que les médecins
bénéficient déjà à ce titre d'aide
financière pour recruter du personnel
c'est une négation de la réalité du
métier de secrétaire médicale dont le
quotidien ne se limite pas à la prise de
rendez-vous à la tenue du standard
téléphonique et à l'archivage des
documents le métier de secrétariat
médical le secrétaire médical comporte
outre sa dimension humaine très forte
une maîtrise de vocabulaire et de la
réglementation des soins une
connaissance des patients cela ne peut
se faire par une mise à disposition de
fonctionnaires uniquement pendant trois
mois comme proposé par le rapporteur
c'est une négation également comme on
souligner les associations d'élules lors
des auditions de la réalité des moyens
des collectivités cela constitue
également une remise en cause du statut
des fonctionnaires l'exposé des motifs
prévoit de transformer des postiers en
secrétaire médicaux et au passage de
casser encore davantage le service
public postal on marche sur la tête en
outre cette proposition de loi prévoit
une disposition discriminatoire puisque
seuls les maisons de santé les cabinets
médicaux pourraient bénéficier de cette
mise à disposition qui exclurait les
centres de santé cette inégalité de
traitement est incompréhensible enfin la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat a mis sa patte libérale en
suggérant d'exonérer de cotisations
sociales le personnel territorial pour
affaiblir encore davantage la sécurité
sociale certainement quand on vote à
votre amendement madame la ministre vous
trouvez que les hôpitaux de souffrent
pas de pénurie de personnel pour les
mettre à disposition des médecins
libéraux vous avez vos soupirer vous
donner de mauvaises solutions à des
vrais problèmes en résumé cette
proposition de loi apporte une réponse
simpliste à un problème complexe et va
engendrer plus de difficultés que de
solution nous assistons à une
compétition des territoires pour attirer
des médecins qui est la conséquence de
l'impuissance organisée des
gouvernements successifs en matière de
formation des professionnels de santé
c'est la conséquence également du refus
de s'attaquer au totem de la liberté
d'installation au détriment de l'accès
aux soins de nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens l'attractivité des
territoires pour les professionnels de
santé reposent moins sur la mise à
disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux que sur l'existence des
services publics école transport
sécurité sociale et sur la proximité
d'un hôpital public malheureusement les
politiques de restriction budgétaire
menée par les différents gouvernements
c'est 20 dernières années dont le vôtre
madame la ministre ont entraîné la
fermeture des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité ainsi que la disparition des
services publics pour moi comme pour
l'ensemble de mon groupe la réponse
politique passe nécessairement par
l'augmentation des moyens des
universités pour former davantage de
professionnels de santé d'un côté et de
l'autre à développer les centres de
santé et à rétablir la permanence
médicale la nuit et le week-end en
revalorisant les gardes et en
réquisitionnant les spécialistes y
compris des établissements privés en
conclusion les sénatrices et sénateurs
du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
voteront contre cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
hello pour conclure la matinée en
respectant l'horaire je donne la parole
à Madame guidez dont le temps de parole
nous permet de clore avant 13h et notre
collègue et amitié au fil reprendra à
14h30
à vous la parole chers collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi
entend accroître les leviers d'action
des collectivités en matière de lutte
contre la désertification médicale pour
ce faire elle vise à ouvrir aux maisons
de santé et cabinet libéraux en zone
Soudan ce bénéfice de la mise à
disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier l'auteur de cette proposition
de loi Monsieur Daniel waterblade pour
son application dans ce dossier
législatif et notre collègue rapporteur
Monsieur Daniel Chassin pour son travail
persévérant son amendement clarifie la
rédaction de ce texte précise des
publics concernés conditionnent le
dispositif à la participation à la
mission de service public de permanence
des soins ambulatoires ensuite il imite
la durée de recours au dispositif à
trois mois renouvelables de fois ainsi
des fonctionnaires mais à disposition ne
seraient se substituer durablement au
personnel propre des cabinets libéraux
et des maisons de santé afin de pallier
tout risque de détournement le
dispositif est enfin conditionné à une
installation récente s'agissant des
médecins exerçant au cabinet libéral
cela permet d'accompagner les médecins à
leur arrivée sur un nouveau territoire
et de les soutenir en leur faisant
bénéficier d'une forme d'avance de
trésorerie sur leur premier mois
d'exercice cela ne voudrait que pour les
zones caractérisées pour une offre de
soins insuffisante ou par des
difficultés dans l'accès aux soins tels
que définit dans le code de la santé
publique ça n'appuie temporaire et
facultatif avant que la maison de santé
ou le cabinet n'est plus recruter son
propre personnel ou bénéficier des
différentes aides proposées par la CNAM
ou les ARS à commencer par les
assistants médicaux certes amusent à
disposition donnent lieu à remboursement
des traitements verser à la collectivité
d'origine mais des conditions de se
remboursement notamment son organisation
dans le temps sont définies par une
convention avec l'administration
d'origine certains s'interrogent sur la
formation et le rôle des fonctionnaires
mais à disposition dans ces structures
par exemple des agents de mairie
officiant comme secrétaire médicaux il
me semble qu'aucune formation spécifique
n'est nécessaire pour accueillir la
patientèle répondent au téléphone de
réaliser l'accessification des dossiers
la grande majorité de nos fonctionnaires
réserve déjà ses activités peut-être
pourrait-on simplement convenir de la
nécessité du respect du secret médical
ce qui suscite des interrogations et de
donner lieu à des ajustements à d'autres
chers collègues le rapport d'information
réalisé par la Délégation aux
collectivités territoriales il y a un an
alerté de gouvernement sur les
inégalités d'accès aux soins dans nos
territoires ces derniers temps plusieurs
initiatives parlementaires ont été
examinés par notre assemblée afin de
pallier le manque criant de médecins
mais cela ne suffit pas j'ai la
douloureuse l'impression que nous
essayons de penser une plaie ouverte non
soignée avec des pansements de premiers
secours qui risquent de se décoller
force est de constater que nous
demandons de plus en plus aux communes
certaines collectivités démunies face à
des départs de médecins sont amenés à
payer la voiture de fonction le logement
et les locaux pour attirer un praticien
sur leur territoire cela donne naissance
à une concurrence déloyale puisque des
communes n'ont pas les moyens financiers
humains suffisants pour activer ces
leviers d'attractivité comment c'est
surtout que ce dispositif encore
n'aggrave pas cette concurrence déjà
bien ancré dans le paysage il s'agit
d'un réel risque pour y creuser les
inégalités territoriales toutefois
compte tenu de l'urgence de la situation
chaque activité tente à sa façon
d'apporter des solutions qui ne sont pas
toujours parfaites nombreux sont des
élus locaux qui de manière volontariste
mettent en oeuvre des dispositifs
innovants et pragmatiques cependant leur
cadre juridique d'intervention reste
limitée même si j'ai eu je dois avouer
des doutes par rapport à cette loi pour
l'ensemble de ces arguments le groupe
Union centrée soutiendra ce texte à ce
qu'il a été modifié par la commission
affaires sociales autrement j'aurais
voté certainement contre mais voilà je
vais suivre mon groupe je vous remercie
de votre attention donc on voudra pour
cette loi
merci de votre exactitude chers
collègues je vais suspendre la séance et
nous reprendrons à 14h30 pour la suite
de l'examen de ce texte la séance est
suspendue